so Jasmine it is so good to see you
again thanks so much for taking the time
to chat with us today for Barbie's dream
house challenge
um I want to talk about this but before
we get to that I want to talk about the
impact that Barbie has on you because I
know you have a daughter and I also know
growing up watching you on the show you
have like this permiance of like
understanding what Barbie is and you
probably played with Barbies growing up
like all of us have so um yeah what was
the impact for for you on Barbie like
what's what do you love so much about
her I think it was so interesting
because when I was asked to do this show
immediately you think about well first
of all what an iconic brand but you
think about like okay how does this how
do I relate with this brand and how you
know what does this mean to me so it's
the same question I asked myself
um and the first thing I thought of was
my daughter she has the Barbie dream
house she has a snowboarder Barbie she
has I don't know a snorkeling Barbie she
has like the all the um one of the barbs
is a doctor which I think is great she
has one that has a she's a baby like the
Barbie has a baby and that's probably
her favorite right now because she's
baby crazy
um but I really spent probably the most
time with Barbie since I've had my
daughter I grew up
um in Virginia in the middle of nowhere
and I didn't spend as much time with
Barbie and my real experience was when I
would go to my friends houses and they
had Barbie and they had all the you know
all the different Barbies and everything
like that and that was when I got to
really spend the most time with Barbie
so it was always this like kind of
coveted uh Toy if you will but also just
the idea of Barbie was always so
inspirational to me and so knowing that
you know there was literally any
occupation or any career that you wanted
to be was represented through Barbie
that was something that I really
connected with I mean I am a woman in a
male-dominated industry and never even
thought twice about that I I was like
yeah this is what I'm going to do and
this is the industry I'm going to be in
and I think that's very Barbie right
yeah and like even like you don't really
notice it but like she is this one
individual in this figure in pop culture
that she breaks like the ceiling like
literally she can do anything and
there's no no one like guess we have the
GI Joes and all that but she is like for
World Peace she is you know a doctor
she's helping she like we have her in
different situations and then we have
her also as a figure for you know pop
culture icons like it's it's so great I
just I love it so much and so even
watching the show I got very nostalgic
seeing all the things um and I want to
talk about the show now because I love
the this Premiere it was so much fun I
watched with my sister and we were like
oh my God I remember that I remember
that like everything was like so cool to
like kind of throw it back to like when
we were younger
um so what was it like for you what was
the most exciting part when you were
renovating and you got to be with uh you
repair it up with Antonia but then your
rival competitors were Egypt and Mike so
what was that like what was exciting
okay so it's always fun to do a big HGTV
show like this because while so many of
us host we have you know our own
individual shows we don't see each other
as much as we would like to just because
geographically we're all over right and
so when we get to come together even if
it's in competition we're so excited and
this was a friendly competition right
everybody won because they were because
we were all building the Barbie dream
house so we were like you know what like
yeah we're gonna be competitive but it
was friendly
um so being able to work with Egyptian
Mike was so fun and I personally am also
a huge Food Network fan like before I
had an HDTV show I was a huge HDTV fan
and when I got an HDTV show obviously it
was like oh of course but I Food Network
is right up there so when I got to meet
Antonia and like be on her show I was a
judge on her show
um and kind of learn uh you know all
that just kind of some of the inner work
things of what it is to have a food show
um it was so fun to work with her as
well that was really a dream come true
but um yeah we got the 1960s for our
kitchen and that was exciting because
that's when Barbie started right and so
we were kind of tasked with the
Nostalgia of the original Barbie and so
for example my mother-in-law when I told
her that I was doing the Barbie house
she was like oh my gosh she's like I
have the first ever Barbie like she has
the very first ever Barbie and she had
the first ever Barbie dream house and
I'm like that's so cool and also really
nerve-wracking because I know there's a
whole generation of fans out there that
this first ever Barbie dream house I
mean Barbie was way ahead of her time
yeah she had her own house
we had everything and it was it was so
like envious like you're like how can
she have everything and then you try to
like emulate it but I don't know it was
just so cute to see everything thing and
I I know that you have renovated big you
know uh there was these events sort of
Renovations we've had on HGTV Brady
Bunch was one of them which was also
very well done
um but you know you were bringing in
those specific elements to life that
there were like literally told to like
bring it like this bring it like that
with the Barbie house it is so different
because there's so many variations to do
with the 60s theme and then there's so
much to work with when you're taking
inspiration from Barbie so like how do
you narrow down what to recreate right
right I that was the question and
um there were definitely things that we
wanted to add into the design that we
ended up not adding in like for example
a black and white checkered floor is
such a big deal and that was um
something that we wanted to have because
it's so indicative of that time period
but we also really wanted to stick with
uh good design if you will and we wanted
it to feel sophisticated and Chic and
like you walk into that kitchen and not
all only is it like you know 1960s and
Barbie but it's also like a kitchen
you'd actually want to use and so that
was the challenge right we might didn't
feel like a toy but we also wanted to
feel like good design and be a great
representation of like what a gorgeous
kitchen can be from any era and I think
that's what Barbie would do so you know
just saying it's interesting with the
with the checkered pattern floor and
then you had this beautiful uh print
that you made I don't want to spoil but
it was so well done because it pulls
back it's like a throwback to something
that's in the Barbie house like so I was
wondering
um how do you how do you how is like
when you're looking into design how do
you know when too much is too much like
I feel like sometimes you don't know it
and you see it on paper and you're like
oh this is great but then when you're
halfway in a renovation you're like oh I
shouldn't have done this like how do you
it's so hard yeah yeah I mean it's so
hard right because
look a lot of times the best laid plans
right A lot of times things look really
good on paper they look great on a
design board and it happens you get in
the field you get into the renovation
and you're like um and I think part of
being you know a good designer or even
like if you're doing your own home is
having the ability to Pivot and be
flexible and know that yeah sometimes
your plan isn't going to go as planned
and you're gonna have to you know come
up with another option and really just
just say it's okay it's okay and that's
kind of like I don't know I think that's
it's really important in design it's
also really important in life right like
so many times we make plans we think
things are going to go a certain way and
they don't and I think that's something
that we can learn from these types of
shows and even just like watching HDTV
in general is that like yeah it's okay
to say you know what I like this or you
know what I thought I was gonna like
this and I don't my bad let's pivot
let's do something different and that's
a hard thing to do I do it all day every
day and I it's still hard for me
um but yeah there's definitely times
where too much is actually too much and
you need to say you know what we need to
Pare this down so that we can really
focus on the things that we're trying to
um you know have speak in the design we
don't want to have so many things
yelling at you when you walk into a room
that it's just overwhelming yeah and I
love that the decade you were assigned
was the 60s because again it was such a
cultural specific time in you know our
American history and so
um Barbie being the innovator that she
was like I was somebody who had the
Barbie magic Voyager I don't know if you
ever saw pictures of it but it's so cute
like everything is something else in the
little Voyager like little RV
um when you came up with the toyetic uh
you know features in the kitchen how did
you know like which ones to use like I
think I thought it was so well done
because it's like I never thought about
those are like space saver sort of
pieces like you can yeah how did you
come up with that okay honestly I'm not
this was the easiest part of the design
for me I think just naturally I never
knew the word like toy attic before this
project but I definitely my brain works
that way right so like I mean I had a
show called hidden potential where
everything was hidden and
multi-functional and purpose and I still
even on help I Rex my house and on my
own projects I always have a hidden room
I always have something that you think
is one thing but it's actually another
thing and I also really love
multifunctional spaces and especially in
the last couple of years you know we've
all started using our homes in very
different ways than we did say five ten
years ago and multi-functional spaces I
think are the thing that have come out
of that in a really positive way people
understand that you might have an extra
room in your house and it needs to be
the guest room it needs to be the gym it
needs to be the home office it needs to
be the playroom it needs to be you know
all these things and is it like a
multifunctional piece basically
something that you would have in a
toroidic feature in a Barbie dream house
so I think that was pretty easy for me
I'm like oh we got this like we know how
to do I know how to do that and Antonio
so game and so excited because anything
kitchen related she was excited about
um so yeah for me it was just like okay
what's fun what's uh something that you
know is going to wow the judges but also
what's really functional like what would
I want if I was Barbie and I was living
in this kitchen yeah that's I I thought
it was so lovely like it was just such a
I was like telling my sister like can
you believe that like that is so
ingenious like just
pop up and it's like okay
um but something that was so interesting
to me was in this competition you're the
only designer who's actually renovating
with someone outside of HGTV so Antonia
is on the Food Network but
um were there any challenges that came
up in terms of being in sync on design
like I know she has designed her own
restaurants but she is in a different
field so things that you would know she
doesn't know and then vice versa yeah
well I actually haven't seen the episode
so that's a fun fact
I will see it with everybody else when
everybody else sees it but I was there
so I know what happened
um but I don't know if this made the cut
or not but I
um especially when we started filming
this had a herniated disc in my neck and
it's been something I've been dealing
with it's really painful and so when it
came time to demo right because we took
a house that was essentially like
straight out of the 1980s the 1990s
um
and when it became time to demo I was
like Antonia I'm really sorry but like
you have to do this I will tell you how
to do it I don't know if this made the
cut or not but I was like I will tell
you how to do it but I need your help
and so she actually swung the hammer and
did all the things that I would normally
do to that kitchen and she loved it she
was so excited she was so sweet to her
dad's a contractor so she always watched
her dad you know do work on her home and
on clients homes her whole life but
she's never actually personally done it
and she was so excited at the end of the
day to like text photos to her dad and
be like look dad like I ripped this wall
down or like I
smash these cabinets
um so that was really fun for her I
think and then no we didn't Clash on the
design she defaulted to me and I loved
hearing kind of her side of things
um and then the the thing that I
defaulted to her on was the food
anything food related she was in charge
of she's an awesome Chef I mean that's
the best part right like if I'm gonna
have a partner that's a chef I'm like
yes I love to eat so yeah of course yeah
I know that on your social media you and
your husband you love cooking and so I
love seeing them too like you and Brett
are so good at like grilling and like
getting steaks out there and it's just
it's really good um but no that TV
dinner was tantalizing like it was so
delicious looking I was like why can't
we have these things like it's like it
looks so good
um so good the mashed potatoes I can't
even explain to you how delicious the
mashed potatoes were like they were so
good it was fitting for Barbie and like
all her friends like I'm sure it was so
good
um but with Antonio you know being a
chef I wonder what were some of the
surprising things that she brought to
the table as a designer that you didn't
ever consider or even like because you
know she's from a different area so
she's in a different expertise was there
anything like that that happened yeah I
think you know she definitely the TV
dinners was a was a big thing where she
was like look like her version or her
um I guess the lens that she saw the
Barbie Dream House through is different
than the lens that I see the Barbie
Dream House through right so like she
has always loved food she's always
wanted to be a chef and so growing up
she would like play with Barbies but
like from a different Viewpoint then
maybe me who was like more tactical and
I'm like okay we're gonna build this
we're gonna set up the rooms I'm like
arranging the furniture and she's in
there with a little like shish kebabs
and the you know setting the table and
like making the food so I thought that
was really interesting as we talked
about like our experiences
um and then I think also you know she
was really excited about the Vintage
like Barbie cookbooks right we had the
original Barbie cookbook on one of the
shelves in our kitchen and that she's
like no we have to put that out like
that's so cool and she's like reading
through all the recipes
um and then just you know some of the
other items like what we put in the
fridge and how we like styled the food
and everything like that she was like
super interested in and then I think she
was just there to learn as far as design
goes she was like oh well like floating
shelves and like how did you choose the
size of these lights and all of that she
was like really really into learning
about that as much as I was into
learning about food she was into
learning about design so I think we made
a good pair from that standpoint it's
very complimentary it works out
um yeah you know one of the things I did
love was seeing you guys interact with
um Egypt and Mike and I thought it was
so funny I was like right it happened
right before the break of you guys when
you broke the wall because you were like
we don't want them to like come back
quickly so we're gonna break the wall
immediately was that like something that
was like happening like a lot in the
house because like there are a lot of
shared walls and I'm wondering if you
have any insight for any of the other
Renovations that were happening or even
just with yours too oh my gosh I mean
look we HTTP hosts we
um are competitive
and I think that um we can't help
ourselves so like we get possessive over
our space like for some reason suddenly
this kitchen and this house was like the
only thing I cared about and the living
room and you know like Egypt and Mike's
area I'm like sorry I'm competitive the
thing is they're just as competitive and
I'm pretty sure they would do the exact
same thing so I I stand by our decision
and I know that the other teams like
it's all love but it's also like all war
like we are competitive so I love that
the other teams um you know they were
just as into it as we were and I know
everybody kind of brought their all had
a lot of fun uh learned a lot along the
way we got to go to Mattel headquarters
we got to like learn about Barbie and
the origins of Barbie and the stories of
Barbie and I think that was really
inspiring as well so yeah I will say
that I know there were a few other tiffs
or riffs or whatever you want to call it
but between the other teams
um but at the end of the day it was all
love yeah and the thing is also like
when you're thinking of Barbie you're
putting it forward for the you know
development of what a Barbie dream house
looks like it's always been open concept
with her like she loves open concept
like even that RV I had like it would
open up and then you'd have like the bed
and you'd have like a picnic table and
like a kitchen
so like everything was there yeah we had
to get rid of that wall and so I you
know we were doing it for Barbie
for the sake of Barbie
um but yeah I know that as a designer uh
colors play a huge part in your world
and pink is not something a lot of
designers play with because it's you
know not as subtle as other colors are
so what does the color pink mean to you
and how and where can we add that into
our own life that's a really fair
question and I I actually use a lot of
color in my design
um and you're right pink is not one of
the prominent ones I have been using a
lot of the like Dusty pinks and like uh
like a rose if you will
um and I use that pretty regularly but
like an actual Barbie pink is definitely
uh it's a really happy color it's a fun
color
um I've had it on my nails for years I
still haven't you see my nails here
so I love a good I love a good pink
manicure and I think that's a way that I
kind of
um
I I don't know yeah I always have my
nails painted pink and I I do have like
pink pops here and there but I've never
done a project with as much Pink as this
house has
um but even the way that we approached
pink in the kitchen I think is a really
good way that you know a homeowner or
someone who likes or prefers pink in
their design can do it and still have it
feel really sophisticated and really um
kind of chic so you know we used pink
our cabinets in the kitchen spoiler our
cabinets are pink but they're not like
ah like in your face pink and so I think
that was the challenge right use as much
Pink as we can but still have it feel
like a really like family-friendly
sophisticated space I love that you know
when you're looking at the Decades of
Barbie you know the in the 60s they're
kind of muted colors like pastels but
then when you go to the 90s they're so
vivid and fluorescent and there's such a
juxtaposition of the coloring when you
get to see it's going to be so exciting
to watch the rest of these episodes
because I'd like to see how the rest of
the house is looking like and it's going
to be so great but oh it's wild yeah
it's wild I cannot wait this has been
such a fun show I do love that this show
uh will not only award one lucky fan the
chance to stay in the dream house but a
donation to save the children's can be
made in the winning pair is honor so um
being on a show like this what does the
entire experience Meant For You
especially when you got to meet the fan
that what you were playing for oh my
gosh I talk about a dedication right I
mean our fan Antonio and I we loved her
she was so hardcore Barbie but also like
the reason that she was a Barbie fan was
such an inspirational story and I mean
she actually moved from Asia to the
United States just to be closer to
Barbie like that's saying something
right
um but it's you know just hearing her
story and understanding why she was such
a fan of Barbie and what it was about
Barbie that Drew her in uh was really
inspirational and it really helped you
know Antonio and I understand like how
important this was not only for her but
just in general making this TV show
being a part of this project and being
able to share just like another version
of Barbie for anyone who is seeking that
right maybe they're seeking inspiration
maybe they're seeking confidence maybe
they're looking for Something to Believe
In and hopefully that's what we gave
them yeah so what can you tease for the
remainder of this season
um it's been so much fun to see already
and I know it's going to be like drama
and like a little bit of competition so
yeah what else yeah I mean it's Barbie
so it's fun I will say that
um there's definitely a lot of
competition there's a little bit of
drama you're right about that there are
some really creative spaces and there's
fun fun fun like it's just all about
um what would Barbie do right like how
would Barbie want her house and taking
and you know you you if you think about
all of us different hosts and the shows
that we have and take that
and then kind of marry that with the
Barbie brand it's really fun because
everybody has such a different Viewpoint
and a different point um you know idea
of what Barbie is to them and it's kind
of so it's like a personal take from
each host as to what Barbie is and then
you add the decades on top of that
um also the judges the judges are
something that I thought was a really
great like HGTV did a great job choosing
our judges and I think that was really
interesting as well so lots of love for
our judges
um and yeah I
I think that the winner is not who
you're going to expect wow I'm excited
I'm excited for that I have to ask you
before I let you go I always love our
chats but did you get to keep your
Barbie doll the answer is yes but I saw
it at Mattel and it was the most
interesting experience because when I
got to meet my Barbie doll at Mattel
um they have a person there and their
job is just to style Barbie
so that no matter how we're standing or
what we're doing maybe we're holding a
sledgehammer maybe we're putting our hat
on it looks so lifelike because that's
they style Barbie I mean talk about a
dream job right so when I'm at my Barbie
I was like oh my gosh like oh like I was
so surreal
um and it is being mailed to me as we
speak I have tracking on my Barbie and I
know what it's gonna get here so I'm
super excited and yes we got to keep our
Barbie I can't wait for my daughter to
meet me as a Barbie that's really what
it's all about I mean as far as like
cool moms go I feel like I'm crushing it
right now you really are I think you've
gotten like the VIP mom like the award
for that you're you're really doing it
um but no I have I'm so excited for this
show I can't wait for everyone to see it
and it's kept coming out around the time
as the Barbie movie which did you get
your tickets because I got my tickets
yes of course you're kidding of course
yes cannot wait to see it so yeah thank
you so much for your time and talking
about Barbie's dream house challenge
which is coming out July 16th and it's
gonna be so much fun it's gonna be on
HGTV and Discovery plus so thanks so
much Jasmine thank you